if we know the position X of T of an
object as a function of time we can use
differentiation to calculate its
velocity and its acceleration at later
times essentially by taking the
derivatives of the position we know
everything there is to know about the
motion sometimes however we'll want to
go in the other direction we'll have the
acceleration as a function of time and
we'll want to find the velocity as a
function of time or the position as a
function of time we'll use a technique
called integration and let's see how
that works to begin with suppose we have
a constant acceleration so our
acceleration a of T is some constant a
not in that case we know that this
constant acceleration can be written as
the change in velocity Delta V over some
time interval delta T and therefore that
the change in velocity Delta V over some
time interval delta T can just be
written as a naught acceleration the
constant acceleration times the elapsed
time delta T and we can see this
graphically if I plot acceleration
versus time here's my constant
acceleration a naught let's say this is
time zero and here's a time delta T the
change in velocity a naught times delta
T is just the area of this box
that box being defined by the time
interval 0 to delta T and it's the area
under the curve a naught so if we know
the velocity at time 0 and we know the
exact on sent acceleration a naught we
can calculate the velocity at any later
time in this way because the change in
velocity from that initial velocity is
given by a naught times delta T now
let's consider a slightly more
complicated example suppose the
acceleration is in constant but is
changing linearly so for a linearly
changing acceleration
I can draw this graphically as well use
acceleration this is Tom equals zero
suppose the acceleration is increasing
linearly and I'll call this time delta T
this is a of T note that we can define
an average acceleration over the
interval from zero to delta T the
average acceleration is the change in
velocity over the elapsed time that
average acceleration will look something
like that
and so then the change in velocity Delta
V is equal to the average acceleration
times the elapsed time and this time
notice from the diagram this product is
actually the area of this trapezoid
that's basically the area under the a of
T function going from zero to delta T
we've calculated it sort of as a
rectangular area involving the average
acceleration but that's also equal to
the area under the time changing
acceleration function so this is again
the area under a of T over the time
interval delta T now let's consider a
more generally changing acceleration as
a function of time so let me plot this
so suppose we have just some general
function I'll draw like this which is
our acceleration as a function of time
the change in velocity will still be the
area under the curve a of T over the
time interval we're interested in so
let's suppose we want to go from this
time here I'll call it T sub a and my
ending time will be king Sabine so we're
interested in figuring out what the area
under this curve is over the interval
from T sub a to T sub B we can estimate
this by breaking up the interval into a
bunch of little rectangles suppose I
break this up into n rectangles just
under this curve okay so this is 1 2 3 4
etc up to n and with each one because
this is a curved graph I can't get the
rectangle to fit exactly so a little bit
if it will stick out at the top and each
one I'm not going to go through that for
all of these but you get the idea I'll
fit these rectangles as well as I can
the narrower I make the rectangles the
more easily I can fit them under the
curve for each strip reach rectangular
strip let's say from heap over box 1
from here to here the change in velocity
is equal to the average velocity over
that time interval times the width of
that rectangle delta T so that's the
area of the strip essentially what we're
saying is that if we make the rectangles
narrow enough we can treat the
acceleration the curve of the very
acceleration as roughly constant over
that interval and we can make n as big
as we need to to make those rectangles
very very narrow okay so in that case we
can estimate the total change in
velocity from time T sub a to time T sub
B by adding up the area of all of these
rectangular strips okay so in that case
we write that the change in velocity so
I'll say V sub B minus V sub a that's
the change in velocity going from time a
to time B is equal to the sum as J goes
from 1 to N of the area of each of these
strips and so we want the acceleration
at the I threat tangle so that's a of T
sub J times the width of the strip which
each strip has the same width we'll just
call that delta T and that's the area of
n strips now for a finite I really
should write this as approximately equal
to because for a finite number of
rectangular strips this is just an
approximation because as I mentioned the
rectangles don't exactly fit under the
curve they can't because the rectangle
doesn't have a curved top but the
function is curved but the narrower I
make the rectangles we're quickly the
larger I make n the better the
approximation will be so what what I
want to do is go to the limit of an
infinite number of rectangles or
equivalently the limit of
infinitesimally narrow strips
I want delta T to go to 0 so to make
this exact what I would write is that
the change in velocity from time a to
time B is equal to the limit of the sum
from J equals 1 to N of the acceleration
at time T sub J times delta T and we
want to evaluate that limit as delta T
goes to 0 or equivalently as n the
number of rectangles goes to infinity
okay now this is a very important
expression
and we have a special way of writing it
we can also write it as an integral so
we write it as the integral of the
function a of T DT evaluated from time
equals T sub a to time equals T sub B
and this is the area under the a of T
curve the exact area not the approximate
area by the exact area under the a of T
curve over the interval from T of a to T
of e this limiting sum that we've
written this way on the right hand side
is called the definite integral of a of
T and it's related to the process of
integration that you've learned about in
calculus which is the inverse of taking
the derivative the inverse of
differentiation I want to take a moment
to summarize the basic principles of
integration from calculus let's begin by
considering a function G of X with some
derivative so consider a function G of X
and let's assume it's a well behaved
function by which I mean that it's
continuous and differentiable over the
interval that we're interested in so
consider G of X
with the derivative so DG DX equal to
another function which I'll call f of X
now note that if I add a constant to G
of X I'll still get the same derivative
so note that the derivative with respect
to X of G of X plus a constant is still
equal to the same function f of X and
this is because the derivative of a
constant is equal to zero now suppose I
want to invert this process then I can
write that the antiderivative of f of X
the antiderivative of f of X which I'll
write as the integral of f of X DX is
equal to G of X plus a constant
okay the left-hand side of this we call
an indefinite integral and so we see
that if the derivative of G of X is f of
X plus a constant the antiderivative of
f of X is G of X plus a constant
Manik and that can be any arbitrary
constant now in calculus one learns how
to calculate the indefinite integral of
various functions polynomials
trigonometric functions logarithmic
functions etc calculus also shows us how
to compute the definite integral so
the definite integral the integral of f
of X DX evaluated from x equals a to x
equals B so this is the definite
integral computed over some interval is
equal to the antiderivative at x equals
B minus the antiderivative evaluated at
x equals a and this turns out to be the
area under the curve f of X in the
interval between x equals a and x equals
B okay now notice that there's no
arbitrary constant in the definite
integral and the indefinite integral we
have an arbitrary constant but in the
definite integral that arbitrary
constant is determined by setting the
integration limits okay so there's no
arbitrary constant we just have this
difference okay and so just to see this
graphically if I plot my function f of X
and suppose this is x equals a and this
is x equals B this definite integral
represents the area under the curve f of
X in the interval from x equals a to x
equals B so calculus tells us how to
solve this area problem how to compute a
definite integral from the
antiderivative that you get from
indefinite integration and so this same
technique tells us how to determine the
velocity from the acceleration since we
saw that that was equivalent to an area
under the curve problem so to come back
to the motion of objects we've shown
that the change in velocity of an object
can be written as the definite integral
of the acceleration so just to
right that a little bit more formally
first with a plot if this is my
acceleration as a function of time we
know that the time derivative of the
velocity is equal to the acceleration as
a function of time I can rewrite that as
the differential DV is equal to a of T
times the differential DT and so then I
can integrate both sides of this
equation by writing the integral over DV
is equal to the integral of the
acceleration a of T DT and I can go from
time equals some initial time T naught
to time equal to some later time T sub
one on the right hand side to make a
definite integral and then on the left
hand side the corresponding limits are
the velocity at time zero I'll call that
V naught and the velocity at time one
which I'll call V one so just to be
clear I'm assuming here that V naught is
equal to the velocity at time T naught
and V one is equal to the velocity at
time T sub one so this is the integral
of a constant over an integral of V this
is an interval of the acceleration over
the time time interval in T and so the
left hand side this is just V 1 minus V
naught and the right hand side without
specifying a of T I can't actually
evaluate this integral I can't specify
what the antiderivative of a of T is
unless I tell you what the function a of
T is so we'll just have to leave it in
terms of an integral and so that's just
the integral of a of T DT from T equals
two not to T equals
T sub-1 so again this shows us that the
change in the velocity from time T zero
to a later time t1 is equal to the
definite integral of a of T over that
interval I can rewrite this in terms of
what the velocity is at some later time
t1 by writing the velocity at t1 is
equal to V naught plus the integral of a
of T DT from T equals T naught to T
equals t1 note that t1 is just any later
time after time T naught where we have
the initial velocity so a more
convenient way of writing this function
might be to write the velocity as a
function of some later time T so suppose
I were to do that I'll just rewrite this
equation replacing t1 with an arbitrary
time T so I have that V of T is equal to
V naught plus the integral of a of T DT
from T equals T 0 to T equals T now
there's something funny here because I
have T in the integration variable here
but I have T as one of my limits here as
well okay whereas if I look at this
expression here there's a difference
between the T in the integration
variable and the limit T 1 they actually
represent different things so to keep
track of that the notation that we
generally use in physics is to call this
integration variable T Prime and so we
write this acceleration of T prime DT
Prime with the time T prime going from T
naught to some later time T now what has
to be cautious here in some fields that
Prime on a variable is used to denote a
derivative differentiation that's not
what it means here I'm writing T prime
just to distinguish it from this
specific later time T that I want to
calculate the velocity at and it's worth
thinking about what this expression
means this equation is identical to this
earlier equation that we derived except
for a change in notation and so let's
think about what that notation means T
prime here is the integration variable
it's a placeholder remember the integral
here the definite integral represents an
infinite sum an infinite sum of
rectangles between a time T naught and
the later time T and that variable T
product Li what I should do now is I
should call this T Prime this variable T
prime is taking every value from T
naught to T so T prime is representing
the running time variable for all of our
strips that we're adding up over this
definite integral okay so it's a
placeholder variable we sometimes call
it a dummy variable it's just a
placeholder to represent time whereas T
the T in the limit here without the
prime represents a specific choice of
later time some later time T where we
want to calculate the velocity so we
know the velocity at some initial time T
naught we'd like to know the velocity of
some specific later time T and to
compute that we have to integrate over
all times running from T naught to T and
that running integration variable we
represent as T Prime just to distinguish
it from the specific time T that we are
trying to compute the velocity for so
now in just the same way that we've
obtained the velocity by integrating the
acceleration we can integrate again we
can integrate the velocity to calculate
the position so given V of T we can show
that the position at time T is equal to
the position at time T naught plus the
integral of the velocity as a function
of time I'll write this as T prime DT
Prime
going from T prime equals T naught to T
prime equals T so this is exactly
analogous to how we computed velocity
from acceleration by integrating a
second time we can go from a velocity to
position so once we know the
acceleration a of T we can use
integration to compute the velocity V of
T if we know the velocity at some
initial time T naught and we can also
compute the position X of T if we know
the initial position at time T naught X
naught so we see that given the
acceleration we can recover the velocity
and the position and as it happens from
Newton's second law if we know the
forces acting on an object that gives us
the ability to compute what the
acceleration is and then given the
acceleration we can use integration to
find the velocity and the position